acelerador a fondo y rosa fluorescente
las irons no pasan inadvertidas en los
circuitos desde 2018 hacen rugir su
motor en los campeonatos mundiales de
resistencia un proyecto que vio el día
gracias a la expiloto francesa debora
Mayer
nos recibieron con un poco de sorpresa
luego finalmente viendo que el proyecto
perduraba prosperaba y que obtenía
resultados la percepción cambió
la percepción entre los resultados más
importantes una victoria en las 24 horas
de espada el año pasado o un tercer
lugar aquí en las seis horas Deportiva
en abril durante las carreras tres
pilotos se relevan al volante de un
Porsche 911 en la categoría lgtm Rangel
Fray Sara Bobby y Michelle gattin ella
se han forjado una reputación de hierro
en un medio en su mayoría masculino
hemos ganado carreras hemos logrado
pauls aquí cuando camino por los paddox
sin importar el que sea en realidad ya
no tengo la impresión de que debemos
probar que merecemos nuestro lugar aquí
ya no lo siento así queremos demostrar
sí que vamos en un auto rosado que somos
mujeres que corremos en un traje rosado
pero que al final del día estamos
compitiendo exactamente Al mismo nivel
que los hombres sobre la pista una
cuarta irons forma parte del proyecto la
prodigio francesa de 19 años doriampa
gracias a su desempeño corre para la
escudería asociada prima Racing en lmp2
la segunda categoría más rápida después
de los hiper
la apodada va a participar por primera
vez en la gran cita de la temporada El
centenario de las veinticuatro horas
delemo
[Música]
Royal
desde pequeño y a los 24 horas la
Fórmula 1 Es lo que siempre quise
alcanzar en mi carrera este año esto se
realiza y es algo increíble
en cambio las demás ya han piloteado en
esta carrera legendaria para la quinta
participación de la escudería ya no se
trata de descubrir este circuito sino de
tener ambiciones concretas
Yo diría que sueño con lograr un podio
en nuestra categoría en y creo que es
importante hablar de los sueños de
atreverme a hablar de ellos
por ahora el mejor resultado alcanzado
es un séptimo lugar el año pasado Dentro
de pocos días las enfrentarán a 20 otras
escuderías en su categoría para
transformar el sueño de podio en
realidad